[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the financial times Whitehall
editor Sebastian Payne and the
journalist and author Rachel shabby so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now the financial time
leads with the protests in Shanghai as
police struggle to disperse large crowds
in a growing wave of discontent at
China's zero covid policies
protesters calling for president Xi
Jinping to resign is on the front of the
Daily Telegraph
that's also the main story in the Metro
with the headline the great brawl of
China
an image of the protest is on the Times
front page but it leads with plans to
bring in Army Personnel to help with
walkouts as strike action Looms
the eye claims Rishi sunak is facing
mounting pressure as he tries to
relaunch his Premiership this week
the guardian says brexit has worsened
the nhs's shortage of doctors leading to
more than 4 000 European doctors
choosing not to work in the UK
labor was accused of trying to price
families out of private school according
to the Daily Mail by planning to scrap
their charitable status
the express claims the government has a
radical new plan to boost the NHS
inspired by cutting down on bureaucracy
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you'll see on screen during
the program it's there now you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Sebastian
Payne and Rachel shabby welcome to both
of you let's start with the financial
times and the situation in China the
protests at the increased Zero Tolerance
regarding covert and the lockdowns that
they are still suffering there Rachel
take us into this
yeah this is a really
um surprising uh wave of protests that
we're seeing in China now it's in its
second day and obviously you've been
reporting on that throughout the day
um this is unprecedented unprecedented
this sort of scale of
um protests in China it's about the
lockdown it's about the covert
restrictions which are now in their
third year
um and the the thing about them is that
they're not just restricted to one city
they're spreading uh across the country
uh they're reported to be in some 50
universities in Wuhan as well as
Shanghai and people openly calling uh
for the president of the Communist Party
to stand down this is just you know
short weeks after he was elected that's
uh Xi Jinping
um into his third term of office uh but
this is just a an eruption against the
um zero covert policy see in the country
particularly jarring against the sort of
Carnival Carnival atmosphere that people
are seeing on their screens around the
world cup where nobody's wearing any
masks nobody's social distancing
um and it just looks like uh China has
had enough
yes they're complaining about the lack
of freedom and what they say is the
unscientific nature of the covid policy
and it does seem as though they they
really have had it enough Sebastian and
they're protesting openly
um in unprecedented scenes
very much so and obviously this is a
very dangerous thing for people to be
doing within China and as you see on the
front page of the Ft main the protests
are holding up a blank sheet of white
paper because that's the only thing they
can do without getting almost certain
arrests and it's obviously something
we've seen in other authoritarian
countries and regimes
um as Rachel just said the world cup
seems to have been a big trigger for
this and we've seen that Chinese State
TV has actually edited footage to make
sure there aren't too many scenes of the
crowds there because of course you can
see the crowds and there are thousands
of spectators not wearing masks in the
way that China has become used to and I
think this is seeped into the the
general consciousness of what they've of
what the rest of the world has realized
which is that a zero covert policy is
not one that is ever going to work or is
ever achievable and to try and maintain
it is taking increasingly authoritarian
aims and ultimately is going to be
unsustainable and the main protests
we've seen are in Beijing Jing and
Shanghai the financial capital and the
general scene suggests that there really
is this big Uprising summer calling on
it's using ping to resign as president
that obviously feels unlikely and you if
you think back to Tiananmen Square and
this has been like to the biggest
protest since that 1989 moment when the
tanks rolled in
um it will probably be met with quite a
lot of brute force from the Chinese
State and particularly if this continues
to spread and this has been bubbling
away for quite some weeks and months so
it's a pretty volatile situation but
it's an amazing thing to see and the
question is does China try and hold its
position on zero covid or does it try
and water it down in some way to try and
appease some of the concerns because
that would be the easiest way out of
this for the Chinese state of course the
best and most natural and right way is
to transition to the kind of covered
policy the rest the world has where you
are living with the the virus you are
vaccinated you accept some transmission
but you're not doing the kind of Rapid
lockdowns constant peace CR testing that
you're seeing across China right now yes
and there are coronavirus outbreaks here
in many of the large cities including
Guangzhou and Beijing as you said but
previous outbreaks have been
successfully suppressed but the state
media Outlets are saying that the
government will continue to put people
in lives first and uh would not waver
from its approach so no sense that the
the government will change their policy
there's zero tolerance policy on covid
the Metro their headline the great Brawl
Of China they're saying um as you
suggested that these are the biggest
process since the 1989 chairman Square
massacre Rachel
well yeah and and the difference uh
between these enchantment square is
obviously social the impact of social
media despite the restrictions in China
but also that these protests are
widespread
um they're not just in one place or one
region but it is interesting that you
mentioned uh rightly that there are
there are no signs that there's going to
be a shift from the zero covert policy
one of the problems that Chinese China
has the main problem is its vaccination
rate is not all that great particularly
for the elderly
um there's only 66 of the over 80 year
olds who have full vaccination and some
40 around 40 percent who've had a
booster
um so there's that but also there's just
the reality that their own
um their own backs vaccine is is just
not as good as vaccines that are made
outside of China which are more rely on
the MRNA structure for the for the for
the vaccine but I don't think that Xi
Jinping is going to essentially lose
Faith lose Faith over the country and
say yeah we need to import
we need to import foreign vaccines
because they're better so it is a bit of
a bind with that and that is why they're
so reliant on these zero covid
strategies which are very extreme and
which of course the rest of the world
has
um you know moved away from and has done
for some time Sebastian to the guardian
and we read that brexit is costing us
European doctors four thousand fewer
European doctors working in the NHS
because directly because of brexit
yes this story does kind of what it says
on the tin there that it looks at that
um and vacancies within the NHS and says
yes there's these um huge extra gaps and
I think and the guardian is reporting um
over almost 11
000 Physicians are needed within the NHS
at the moment and the paper citing
research from the nuffield trust are
very well respected Healthcare think
tank that says extra red tape and
bureaucracy are leading to many EU
doctors who come to the UK to train in
medicine going back to EU countries
afterwards and of course these are the
kind of barriers that were going to be
brought up following the decision to
leave the EU in 2016 and it's the kind
of obvious thing where we've got
vacancies within jobs Market why is the
government doing something about it that
you know we've taught for quite a long
time about the need to add targeted
visas for a particular part of the
economy and the NHS is one that clearly
needs it and there's a story on on the
other papers I think it's the times
saying that uh the Army is going to be
drafted in to try and help move move
ambulances and medicines and supplies
around over the winter months I mean if
you've got a clear problem with the
bureaucracy and the red tape of brexit
involved here that should be liberalized
as opposed to getting army trucks and
tanks going around around the country
and of course all this is going to be
exacerbated by the continued levels of
strikes particularly the nurses of
course who are going on strike over the
pay dispute so it's going to be a very
tough win for the NHS this is the first
winter where covert has not dominated
for three years but you've got the
strikes you've got the vacancies so it's
a pretty unhappy picture yeah it's also
a ballot action on 15 000 ambulance
workers that due this week as well just
time for the metro and who's coming back
to reality Rachel
well Hancock he's out
um and he's going to come back to UK
just in time for the next round of the
uh covert inquiry I think which seems
appropriate given that he Bears so much
of the responsibility of what went wrong
uh the excess deaths
um the failure to protect the vulnerable
the hiving off millions of pounds to buy
dodgy PPE and Dodge it and paying dodgy
tests and Trace companies that went up
to the job so yeah about time he came
back and actually faced some real
scrutiny I think Sebastian do you think
he's rehabilitated himself in the in the
final three in I'm celebrity it's a
surprise he stayed in so long
I am very surprised I was one of the
many people bemoaning in a hand-wringing
sense what a dreadful idea this was for
MPS for democracy for the conservative
party but Matt Hancock went into the
jungle with a very clear aim and I'm
afraid to say it's been relatively
successful he went in to develop his
reputation and Beyond politics to try
and gain some sympathy become more of a
celebrity and that certainly happened if
you look on the comments of various
websites or on Facebook on other social
media their Matt Hancock has certainly
done gone a long way to try and feel
more sympathetic towards him he didn't
win which obviously something he would
very much wanted to do but I think
coming third when he went in so
unpopular so disliked by the other
um campmates within the jungle he'll see
that as probably a clear victory in the
fact it's on several of the front pages
tomorrow speaks to what he was trying to
aim I'd imagine he will come back I'd
also Imagine he'll probably Stand Down
from Parliament at the next general
election and we'll be focused on in Ed
Boar's Edwina Curry and whitakam style s
post parliamentary career instead of
dealing with the covert inquiry of
course which is the most pressing thing
right now but uh yeah the whole thing is
just utterly bizarre yes uh Sebastian
and Rachel for the moment thank you we
are going to take a break but coming up
Fury over starmer class war on private
schools that's according to the Daily
myth
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Financial Times
white wall editor Sebastian Payne and
the journalist and author Rachel shabby
let us have a look at the telegraph
um and this is some advice that we are
being given to turn boilers down to to
60 uh degrees this is going to be part
of a two-pronged strategy spearheaded
bike Grant chaps the business secretary
but we were previously told that it was
be Nani state if the government did
advise us on energy saving measures um
there's been a change of mind
Sebastian
yes I I mean I thought was always
ridiculous the idea the government
wasn't going to give basic advice during
an energy crisis and we're learning that
this um um this this announce this
information scheme is going to start
tomorrow 18 million pounds being spent
to tell people how to basically save
energy and of course the idea is the
cumulative effect of this across
millions of households will help save
the government billions in the longer
term in terms of their energy support
package and one of the things is to turn
your boiler down to 60 degrees though I
imagine many households have just not
had that boiler on Full Stop
um so I don't think they'll be listening
to that to turn radiators off in rooms
that you don't use keep windows closed I
mean a lot of it is basic common sense
but it's very good to be reminded of it
by the government to keep in that in
people's memories this is an energy
crisis we do all need to try and do our
best and I think most people I know put
on an extra jumper and not put the
heating on until they've absolutely had
to and but I think we wasted so much
time under the Liz trust government
where essentially she refused to do any
thing is part of her kind of you know
anti-nanny state drive but to me it just
felt really silly because you've got to
try and do something because at the
moment the energy support package is
costing the government's hundreds of
billions of pounds that's so much money
and anything you can do to reduce that
is essential but apparently this
campaign is not about telling people to
wear an extra jumper that's completely
the wrong idea that's not to where where
they're they're heading um let's have a
look at the mail Rachel and this story
about Labor's plan well that their war
against private schools uh prizing uh
parents out of that market
I mean it's very it's a very typical
sort of Daily Mail headline isn't it
it's all ramped up hysterical reaction
to something that is just trying to
um level the playing play level the play
playing playing field and equalize
opportunity in the UK but it would it
would mean it would mean parents paying
more parents with children in private
schools will be paying 20 more on their
fees under this this plan from secure St
armor
the people voyaging war in this country
at the moment in the education sphere
are private schools private schools are
the ones that all aging class wore
um there's only 77 of the population is
educated in private school and yet they
dominate all positions of power across
politics across media across law
um that clearly has to stop that's
clearly not a fair system in the UK and
what labor is proposing is purely trying
to address and rectify that
isn't it just about making people pay
more though Sebastian
I mean I'm not really a fan of this
proposal I just don't think it's like
the main focus or argument labor should
be having at the moment it's kind of a
classic Retreat into class Warfare as
opposed to folks on the much more
substantive issues that we've still got
this economic fiscal black hole which
labor hasn't put any explanation forward
of how exactly it wants to fill it um
obviously the Daily Mail is doing the
kind of thing the Daily Mail does and be
a b pretty top thumping right wing about
these things but fundamentally I just
think that this is not really a priority
right now and if parents want to send
their kids to private school then they
should be allowed to do that and I just
think as you said it is ultimately going
to result in parents paying more and of
course don't forget parents who send
their kids to private school are
essentially paying double because
they're funding State schools do their
normal Taxation and then paying extra on
top of that I don't think moving
charitable States is a good idea and
many private schools reinvest back into
the state sector as well through free
schools sponsoring academies
scholarships we must leave it there we
will continue this in the next hour
Sebastian Rachel for the moment thank
you